okay thank you for inviting me so yes
we're gonna change timescales and we're
gonna look at genetic variation across
species and how you use that to
reconstruct the evolutionary history of
several species and particularly the so
called Tree of Life so I my main goal is
really just here to give you a very
high-level idea of what sort of the
basic phylogenetic reconstruction
problem how what are the sort of basic
classes of models that are used and sort
of the different types of methods that
are used to solve these zombies this
inference problem if I have time we'll
see how how it goes I might see a little
bit about some insights from work that
came out of the theoretical computer
science community about these methods
but I overall also will stay at a very
high level if you'd like to have more
details let me before I forget just tell
you right away
- classic references simple in steel
phylogenetic goes into maybe the more
mathematical side of things are they
cover especially a lot of this are
combinatorial and algorithmic aspects of
the phylogenetic reconstruction problem
it's a great reference and then
Feltenstein
as this also a classic book about maybe
the more statistical side of things and
the more pragmatic things I'm gonna
stand the sort of theory side of thing I
won't tell you much about if anything
about implementations or particulars oft
where or and so on but I'll my
perspective will be maybe a little bit
in between if you want more
now I talk about have a whole series of
lecture notes just Google okay so just
to make sure everybody's on the same
page let me tell you what the Tree of
Life is suppose that you have a bunch of
related species say these are Darwin's
finches it's a bunch of birds that live
in the Galapagos Island is sort of a
islands there's a classic evolutionary
biology example and the way that they
are thought to have evolved at least the
Wikipedia level understanding good as
suppose that there was maybe an
ancestral population that originally may
be one one one species that live on
maybe there's big island over here and
then at some point maybe a group of
birds migrated to a different Island and
they became reproductively isolated from
the original group of birds and they
slowly started evolving to a different
environment maybe their beaks change
over time because of a different food
sources and so on and eventually sort of
formed their own species
I won't define what species is but then
maybe this process so repeated itself
many many times and you had different
species sort of evolving on different
islands and that sort of led to the
current diverse diversity of these
species maybe there's a different
different ones that are so different
morphological characteristics one is a
neat way to represent graphically this
this history is what a tree and ice or a
connected graph without a without cycles
this is taken from Darwin's notebooks
presumably this big one here was the is
the root of the tree that was the sort
of ancestral population and every
branching of the tree corresponds to a
new species being created so think about
these birds that are moving to a new
islands this sort of becoming
reproductive
isolated forming their own species and
then they sort of evolved independently
from the original branch and that
repeats itself over and over and you get
this tree that gives you the sort of
evolutionary history of the other
species the tips of the tree are either
maybe extinct species or sort of
contemporary and existing species so for
example a B C and D here would be for
different contemporary species of these
finches faith and our goal is to
reconstruct this tree and also possibly
some information about what happened
along these branches maybe as some
parameters of some mutation processes or
maybe some mutations that have occurred
and so on but first maybe before I
explain how we do that thing I should
say a little bit about why why you
should care about the Tree of Life I saw
this this is a whole industry in biology
of building these trees and I'll say a
little bit about how you do this in a
second but why why do biologists care
about this well it's as I said it's a
some neat graphical representation of
the history of life it gives you a nice
way to sort of classify species
according to evolutionary principles but
from a sort of data analysis perspective
I mean it's this it gives you this sort
of very important structure that you
have to take into account when you're
analyzing data across different species
and maybe it's easier to understand on
an example let me just go through this
example here this is called phylogenetic
profiling suppose that you are suppose
that you're studying a new protein you
don't know what it does you don't know
what's function you don't know so it
interacts with other proteins but you've
observed the following thing there's
this other protein that's very well
understood say p1 that happens to haves
or a known function and you've noticed
that you know you collected data from
multiple species and remember here the
tips of the trees are these different
species and you've noticed that every
time species has a copy of the first
protein it also has a copy of the second
protein and when it doesn't have a copy
of the first protein it doesn't have a
copy of the second protein and you might
use that as evidence that maybe these
two proteins are somehow related to each
other maybe they have
a related function there in the same
pathway or something like this but you
know how confident you should be in
guessing that these two proteins are
related really depends on the
evolutionary history of these species
and which one of these to give the
strongest evidence that these two
proteins are really related to each
other and the one the one on the on the
right be because this one can easily be
explained by chance I say if you think
about maybe the ancestral species here
ad copy of p1 and p2 and along this long
branch just by chance p1 was lost and
pizza was lost which is completely
unrelated reasons and on everybody down
here just doesn't have any of these two
are or has non-functional versions of
these two whereas if you look on this
side in order to sort of try to explain
what you're looking at here if this you
know history is correct it would seem
that maybe the most likely scenario here
is that maybe the original speed the
ancestor had a copy of each one of them
but then it was lost multiple times in
separate events and each time when one
was lost the other one was lost and so
maybe one once one of these since
they're their functions might be related
if one of them is not working anymore
then the other one has just no function
anymore and it just you gets eaten up by
mutation and eventually you sort of see
this pattern so the claim is if you take
a check on the evolutionary history you
get this much stronger evidence that
there's a connection between these two
proteins and in general you know if
you're studying zuv data or cross
species this is sort of something that
you want to take into it ok so we're
going to assume that this is an s of an
important thing to reconstruct and we're
going to start looking at how our
biologists actually reconstruct in the
tree
okay so how do you reconstruct the Tree
of Life but before the advent of
sequencing technologies the way that you
might go about doing this would be by
you know you're studying a bunch of
species and often certain groups of
related species are going to be
characterized by sort of common features
maybe morphological features or
physiological features that you're
studying a bunch of lizards and there's
a few of them that squirt blood at their
predators to sort of confuse them and
there's a bunch of them that don't and
so then maybe that's blood squirtin
thing evolved once and all of the sort
of descendant of the ancestor got that
are part of this sort of subgroup and
general you could find lots of different
features like this that sort of
characterize different subgroups of
species if you go to the the museum
natural of Natural History in New York
they have this really wonderful exhibit
where you can sort of walk through the
tree of life and for each branch of the
tree they have these fossil that sort of
show you that the features that
characterize the different groups that
sort of emerge from this branch and and
it can indeed sort of reconstruct large
parts of the of the Tree of Life using
this kind of thing but the sort of the
modern way of getting a much sort of
finer understanding of the evolutionary
history of species is to look at DNA
data okay so the idea is I have a bunch
of species here and I'm going to collect
sequence DNA from all of them and maybe
I've identified a gene that sort of
common to all of them and I'll get the
sequence of of this gene and by
comparing the gene sequences I want to
learn something about the evolutionary
history of the Tree of Life the the very
high-level idea
Montee this morning explained that was
you know the further apart two species
are in the tree the more sort of
mutations I've accumulated on sort of
the path from the the original the most
common and
and therefore the more different the
sequences are going to be and and so
that tells you something about the
relative positions of things in the tree
the the details of how you actually get
this tree are actually interested in
involved I guess from from mathematics
statistics and computer sciences so I
want to give you just a little bit of
flavor of how that's done okay so our
goal here is to reconstruct a tree
there's other things that you might want
to make you're stuck along the edges and
I said but let me just sort of focus on
the tree itself and we're actually going
to be interested in a special kind of
tree which is a tree with labeled leaves
okay so the leaves are here play a
special role right this is where the
data lives this is where the
contemporary species are and the labels
of the leagues are going to correspond
that the names of the species of honey
to each one of these lately yes I'm
interested in reconstructing a leaf
labeled tree it's not just the the sort
of structure of the tree that I want is
the relative positions of the different
species on the trees is is dog closer to
cat or is it closer to Mouse and so on
there's sort of different representation
of this of this kind of object that
turns out to be interesting from a
computational statistical inference
point of view one is is to think of leaf
label tree instead as a collection of by
partitions okay so suppose that I look
at I have a particular tree here with
the leaves labeled I take any edge in
the tree say this particular edge well
that edge defines a by partition of the
leaves there's the leaves on one side
and then there's the leaves on the other
side okay so for every edge in the tree
I define this by partitions of the
labels of the leaf and so I get a
collection of by partition now it turns
out that I can go the other way around
if I give you all of the by partitions
and they're all sort of correct then you
can easily sort of reconstruct
reconstruct the tree in a words how do
you do this suppose that I give you all
these by partition well one way to do
this
there might be several ways of doing
this might be to say well I'm gonna see
a bi partition that corresponds to these
two guys on one side and everybody else
on the other side and so that I know
that these sores are siblings or the
first-level they're just it's full of
cherry um and so I could identify this
this first bit of the tree and I merge
them into a cluster a sort of super node
and then I look at my bar partitions
again where I sort of removed one of
them and I represent the two of them by
one of them and then I just would beat I
find the next cherry and so on and so
what's gonna happen is I'm going to
slowly build this tree sort of one
cherry at a time one branching at a time
until I get the entire tree
yessuh from a tree I can get the by
partition from the by partitions I can
get the truth nothing useful down
representation
here's another representation I can
think of the tree as a notion of
distance metric on the leaves and that's
directly related to the high-level idea
that I just told you about right suppose
that I take this tree here and I
assigned to every edge a positive weight
so this this this weight could be say
the time elapsed between these two these
two a speciation events or it could be
the expected number of mutations in a
gene along that branch of the tree now
if I assign to every edge of the tree at
positive white then I get a distance
between every pairs of leaves which is
defined in the following now if I take
two leaves it's a tree so there's a
unique path between them and I can sum
the weights along that path and I get a
number which I'm going to call the
distance between in this case C and D I
can do this for every pair and I get a
notion of distance it's actually a
metric satisfy the triangle inequality
and so it's a special kind of metric
called an additive metric in general
satisfies this sort of a set of
inequalities here at the bottom and
again it has this this nice neat
property that it's invertible if I give
you an additive metric on a finite set
well there's a unique tree instead of
it's up to potentially some of the
genera sees that outputs the same metric
again yes sir
if I if I'm given an additive metric I
can get back a trick that will be one
way of reconstructing trees in a second
how do I do this again let me just tell
you at a very high level well what you
do is you compute this this quantity
here so suppose that I am suppose that I
am only for spore species I'm ignoring
their root here you'll see in a second
it turns out that it's some of the
statistical model that we're going to be
using the root is is not identifiable so
I'll often work directly with unmuted
trees so there's this sort of no natural
notion of time here if I have four
leaves and I assume that I have these
binary internal those every internal
let's say they're green every three just
to simplify you can generalize this then
there's really only three different
topologies leaf label topologies on
these four leaves and it's always the
same tree structure but the relative
position are different right so a could
be next to be it could be next to C or a
could be next to D so that gives me my
tree different leaf label topologies
under these these conditions and now
suppose that I give you an editor of
metric on these four leaves and and you
want to figure out which of these
topologies am I looking at
well it turns out that you can figure
this out by computing this quantity like
if I compute the distance between AC
plus the distance between BD minus a B
minus C D I get something different on
these three different topologies so if I
snuck over there some other the true
thing was a B on one side and Sydney on
the other well AC plus BD minus a B
minus C D what is going to happen here
because it's additive of course this a
discounted positively when I added here
but it's kind of negatively when I
subtract over here so it's gonna cancel
out this one's gonna cancel though this
one's gonna cancel okay so what what am
I left with is twice the length of this
middle edge I'm gonna get something
positive if the true topology instead
was this one or the one that generated
this additive metric was this one then
I'm gonna get exactly the opposite right
so AC plus BD
- a B - C D you do the cancellations
again now you get - twice the length of
this middle edge you get something
negative and you can convince yourself
at if you do this over here you get
you're gonna get zero okay so if I give
you an additive metric on four leaves in
principle you can figure out which one
of these topologies you're looking at
now in general if you have more than
four leaves what do you do there's lots
of different ways of doing this but you
could for example take every four tuple
of leaves for each one of them you apply
this test to figure out what the
topology is to this restricted set of
four leaves and then you get this sort
of puzzle and so these are overlapping
you know they have leaves in common and
now you just have to put them together
and get the entire tree in the case
where you get one a quartet these are
called quartet one quarter tree for
every four tuple and they're all
consistent with one tree then there's a
sort of an easy way of reconstructing
the tree that it corresponds to that
sort of similar for example there's many
ways probably but the the previous slide
where I I was sort of finding one cherry
at a time you could do something very
similar here I'm and recovery or recover
your tree so these are different
representations of the output what is
the input the input is a set of a set of
sequences one for each of my species and
the information that I'm trying to get
out of it is the the mutations that I've
accumulated over time right that Monty
this morning talked about this molecular
clock assumption where in each in each
branch of the tree the sort of mutations
are accumulating and it's a roughly
constant rate and therefore if you can
sort of measure how much mutations have
occurred between two species that tell
you something about Alf far paths in the
past they sort of diverged from their
most common recent ancestor all through
some common ends okay so what I'll need
is to turn this into a statistical
problem is a model of our DNA evolves
on an evolutionary tree okay so this is
sort of maybe the simplest one that it's
called a Juke scanner model because I've
got my tree this is the evolutionary
tree that connects these these five
species again the leaves are the
contemporary species you can think of
this guy as the root and the branches
and the internal nodes are sort of the
ancestors at this level we're going to
ignore the the population level
variation okay so we're going to assume
that the differences between species are
sort of much bigger than the the
differences inside each one of these
population so instead of we're not going
to model each one of these populations
instead we're just going to imagine
taking one reference sequence from each
one of them and we're just going to
track the evolution of that sequence on
the tree yes I'm going to start at the
root of the tree with a sequence okay so
I'm looking at a particular gene say it
has a sequence of AC G's and T's that's
the my reference sequence from that
ancestor which I don't have access to
but right now all I'm doing is
describing the model of evolution and
then we'll get back to the actual so
just a go problem of inferring
everything okay so I'm going to imagine
that the the root adds some sequence and
then what happened over time is that
mutations accumulated okay and I to
simplify the sort of standard assumption
is to assume that the sites are actually
independent and identically distributed
so it's the same model for every site
but it's happening independently from
site to site okay so if I focus on one
particular site I ignore the other ones
the ancestor as a G over here and I'm
going to imagine that for so that the
tree here is deterministic I'm not going
to try to model our maybe evolution of
these sequences as influence the
structure of the tree I just have this
tree that exists I mean we're just gonna
imagine that I have these sort of
neutral mutations that I've accumulated
along the tree and now what's going to
happen is that along each branch of the
tree there's going to be a certain
probability that I have
a change by the end of that branch okay
so I started with a G over here and the
sudden probably I'm going to change by
the time I get to a and if I change at
least in this very simple Japan or model
I can have uniformly any of the other
states same thing over here there's a
probably of adding a change so in this
case there was no change in this case
there was a change
I went from G to C okay so each branch
has something probably of flipping the
parent independently of everything else
and I'm not flipping out changing the
parent and if you change it just jump
from one to the but the other is
uniformly ever so you're going to do
that starting from the root moving away
from the road all the way to the leaves
I'm actually going to get a state for
each one of the for each one of the
leaves and I imagine repeating that
independently for each of the sites of
the ancestor where I end up with is a
sequence for each of the for each of the
leaves and so each come inch
contemporary species gets one copy so
descended from with modification from
the from the ancestor so far no so I
could definitely generalize and imagine
that there might be several speciation
occurring at the same time I could
represent this by saying that I have a
very very short edge between the day at
the Afrin in a succession and it's a
very very short edge between them so
it's sort of often without much loss and
generally we assume that we have a sort
of binary tree but where some of these
edges might be maybe arbitrary short and
so even though I what I'm going to talk
about is always going to be binary in
this way you can generalize a lot of
these things too
they did I think the this guy had some
trifurcation site this one right there
oh you get more like this is a quad
that's right it's not just academic
interest these things are real there's
lots of things we're on the level of
resolution that we have from the data
that's we might not be able to really
see now I said along each - within
probability of changing maybe it more
maybe a more sort of accurate way of
describing this is that along each one
of these branches I have a continuous
time Markov process that jumps from
state to state along along this branch
even though I start at a G and I ended
up at G in the middle there might be
some excursions to see a G and
eventually you ended up at G so in
general I'm going to imagine that I have
a certain rate matrix this is not going
to be really important if you don't like
continuous time stochastic processes but
you have a rate matrix that tells you at
what rate I jump from one state to
another along each branch I have a
preset for information which is how long
do I run this process and so the time
elapsed between these two speciation
event and I'm also a badge in that I
have a mutation rate now Marty this
morning talked about it so if you have a
continuous time process like this you
can write the transition matrix
corresponding to the jump from here to
there as this exponential now Montee
this morning talked about the molecular
clock assumption you said that there's a
lot of evidence that the mutation rate
at least if you look at a particular
protein it might change from protein to
protein but if you look at a particular
protein that's often sort of tends to be
very fairly constant across species in
general that's not quite true especially
if you look at larger solute timescales
and there might be some differences
maybe in generation times that that
affect the rate of mutations and the
standard practice in in phylogenetics
is to assume that you have a mutation
rate that might actually change from
branch to branch if I'm gonna have this
new e here
which is the rate at which these
mutations are occurring for a particular
site now of course in general I could
have also a more general matrix Q here
I'm assuming that the jump from a to all
of the other ones is always sort of
symmetric but you can go beyond the
droop scanner model have a sort of more
general transition matrix where rate
matrix that where certain transition
might be more likely than others but you
can take all of that into account now
what I have not done here in this model
is to take into account some other
things that happen that are important
and one of them is this idea of
insertions and deletions right right now
what I'm assuming is that the only thing
that happens is that at a certain main
rates you have substitution that G
becomes an A or C becomes a T there's
other things that happen so insertions
and deletions might happen would create
new sites or some site might disappear
or a bunch of sites at the same time
might disappear that's taken into
account I'll come back that maybe at the
end if I have time I'll just take that
into account by doing this first
pre-processing phase where they align
the sequences and try to guess where
these insertions and deletions have
occurred by filling with gaps instead of
trying to figure out which side
correspond to which I'll come back to
that at the end but we'll assume that
this was done and that we have a data
set that sort of been clean of
insertions and deletions another
interesting thing is to look at
different sites might evolve at
different speeds that for example
because of the genetic code every Church
position is a very redundant and is less
influenced by potentially selection and
therefore there might be more changes
there than in other places and so to
take that into account biologists will
allow a rate of evolution that actually
changes from site to site so you would
have another thing here that's random
that depends on the actual position in
your genome but I'll ignore that
any questions about this model before I
move on to the actual statistical so if
you if you if you include some maybe a
more general rate matrix and these rates
of cross sites including maybe some
sites that never change and others that
would change the sort of a random rate
you get a sort of a very standard model
that's used in biology the model al DNA
that changes across a and evolutionary
oh maybe I should mention so there's
some interesting connections are
statistical physics this basic model is
sort of related to the so-called Potts
model or free boundary and the
theoretical computer science community
in particular there's been some
interesting work about how to exploit
these connections and the knowledge
about this kind of model but I don't
think I'll be able to talk about them ok
so what is the actual statistical
problem now I'm imagining now that I
don't actually know the tree all I know
is I have a certain number of species
and I'm getting a sequence for each one
of them that I've been already allowing
so I can think of them as iid samples so
these sequences are like iid samples
from a Juke scanner model or more
general Markov model on a tree and my
goal is to go from these sequences these
samples to the actual tree that
generated the data yes so the leaf leaf
label tree and potentially you know
information about Q and the mutation
rates at the time or at least the
product of mutation rates and time along
all of these branches that's my basic
problem so the input is I have a bunch
of sequences so s a1 is the sequence at
species a this is a bad nutrition
species a might be this guy here the
first positions of it would be this one
and then I have K a length K gene I can
imagine and so I have K site C or K
samples and for each one of my species
and now my goal is to find a map that
starts from these sequences and so for
each species
species by L here I have for each
species a sequence of like a and I want
to map that to the space of trees which
I need to know TN I want to put a tree
that's a well-defined statistical
problem well let's see that it's well
defined there's so there's there's a
whole industry of coming up with methods
for solving this basic problem and if
you're interested in in sort of
analyzing theoretically I'll get these
methods are and sort of understand
better their behavior there might be
sort of two basic criteria that you're
interested in one is well how efficient
are they computationally speaking right
so if I'm nowadays biologists might be
constructing trees on tens of thousands
of species and the number of trees that
have 10,000 leaves is you know
astronomical so you cannot just look at
each one of them and see which one fits
your data best you have to come up with
a computationally efficient way of
fitting the data to your deer model the
other side of course is how accurate is
this reconstruction first of all is this
problem even well define there's this
question of identifiability if I am is
it the case that right so imagine that I
give you infinitely long sequences
you're basically I tell you what the
distribution is of each one of these
site is it the case that there's only
one tree and one set of parameters that
outputs that particular distribution and
for the particular model at least that I
that I showed you in the previous slide
you can actually show that indeed each
each tree and branch lengths gives rise
to a different distribution and
therefore in principle if you haven't
finicky long sequences you should be
able to get back the model things change
if you look at rates across site for
example I'll come back to Vienna five
okay so the problem is in principle
well-defined and so one sort of natural
thing that biologists have been looking
at is is my algorithm consistent well
this consistency mean and means that as
the sequence line goes to infinity and
of course the real Sigma
or finite but if I imagine that I
generate infinitely many samples from
this from this process is my algorithm
my reconstruction algorithm guaranteed
to recover the correct tree with
probability one element this is called
statistical consistency and it's sort of
a basic requirement when you're so
designed that's very constructive yes
that's that's a great question and so
it's it's it's really not obvious to to
say anything about real data because we
don't know the truth and so it might be
difficult to actually know what the real
tree is you might have other information
may be fossil data or geography or other
things that that biologists might use
where if you showed them a tree they
might say this is definitely wrong
but in general we sort of don't know
what the truth is and therefore it's of
hard to to assess the performance of
algorithms or even how good models are
by looking at real data so in practice
what biologists are computer scientists
that work on this kind of thing do is
they do simulations of course and
they're you know the truth and you can
see at least under sort of very
potentially unrealistic conditions how
your algorithms do it it's a sort of a
non-trivial problem to go beyond that
okay that's a good bit that's a good
point
bye there there might be something that
you can do good this is an interval
where do you like have the genomes and
half the genome separately like
bootstrap that's maybe that's just
showing that the things customs itself
right since it's not really that's right
so here I'm going to assume that these
models make sense and don't they tell
you something about no as far as I know
biologies have been using them and have
been generally sort of happy with when
they're reconstructed that's worth so
they must have some bearings to real
okay so what are sort of standard
methods for reconstructing trees I'm not
gonna go through all of them as I said
it's basically as being this sort of
three standard for the categories of
methods the first one I've already
hinted at which is this notion of a
distance matrix and yes I said if I if I
imagine that on my tree I put weights
that correspond to the expected number
of mutations say on that branch I can
define this notion of metric which is
you know the total expected number of
mutations between two leaves and and
from there I can actually get a tree
uniquely and inefficiently it's a sort
of a easy to have to build a tree from
there the true additive metric how do I
get this from the data right so it turns
out that if you this lambda or EE remain
there's a citizen's lambda e here is my
branch length you remember this is a
mutation rate te is the the length of
the branch and time if I imagine again
putting these weights on my branches it
turns out that under the JIP scanner
model and there's more general formulas
if you have a more general model it
turns out that the sum of the weights on
a path between two leaves can be
rewritten in terms of the model as this
expression okay so it's a log of
something and that something is the
probability that if I look at say the
first position in species a and the
first position precedes B what is the
probability that they disagree but
there's something different there okay
there's a there's a log here so now what
happens is that you know since you only
see the end point that you might as I
said before there might be is that a
whole trajectory between them while
you're
keep jumping from one thing to another
you're only seeing the end point and so
they're lies until not take it to a
counties or hidden mutations but at the
end of the day you can relate this
notion of distance to something that you
can actually see in the data all right
so now what do I do to estimate this P I
take my two sequences and I just count
often they disagree and so the fact of
frequency of disagreement will give me
an estimate of that if I plug that into
that formula it gives me an estimate D
hat a B of my distance matrix well this
is the distance matrix yes I can think
of it as a matrix if I look at every
pair these are my leaves for every pair
of leaves I have this estimate of the
distance between them which I call the
distance matrix and methods that start
from there to build a tree are called
distance matrix methods and so for
example if I just apply the the basic
idea that I had before which was this
idea that you reconstruct Quartet trees
and then you put them together that
gives me one way of reconstructing the
tree here's another way so there's lots
of different ways of doing this I
suppose that I have a molecular clock
this time and so the mutation rate is
the same everywhere so what that means
is mu E is equal to some fixed mu for
every e let's call the molecular clock
assumption then I actually have a rooted
tree now I can actually identify there
what everything is at the same distance
from the root so there's a sort of
special node which is the root and if I
assume that my data was generated on a
tree I under a tree like this I can
easily reconstruct it free by doing and
irq called clustering kind of scheme
right so I can look at the distance
between every pair and the two closest
ones are going to be this cherry over
here so the two plus is 1 over cherry in
the tree
and so I can group them together by just
identifying which for inserted two
closest and then I think of them now it
was a super know that removed the
corresponding row and column 0 4 5 and
now I have for this sort of super node
and then I just start over I look at the
two closest ones well this time is going
to be
- I put those together and then now I
have three super nodes a two Sopranos I
just original three and then I look at
the two clauses again is gonna be this
one two or three and I do this again
until I only have one super node left
and if you sort of unroll this process
what you get is the sequence of clusters
that corresponds to the tree yeah so a
very basic method here would just be to
of this clustering approach now this
will work perfectly if I have exact if d
@ is exactly equal to D in reality of
course depending on how much data I have
or whether the model is right I might
I'm gonna get an estimate of D hat of D
right and so this process might fail at
some point I might get the wrong
clustering and in order for this to work
well basically it has to be the case
that these sort of the errors that
you're making are and be smaller than
maybe the smallest branch of the tree
that's if that's correct if that's the
that's true
this procedure basically is going to
work there's lots of other ways of doing
this typically you'll get a polynomial
time algorithms there of statistically
consistent because just by the law of
large numbers the estimate for this as K
goes to infinity as my sequence line
goes to infinity it's just going to
converge to that quantity and once I
have the correct quantity if I use an
algorithm that's at least works on the
real thing on the real edited metric
then in the limit once I have enough
precision here I'm going to be
guaranteed to get the correct a tree
with high probability not all of these
methods are polynomial times for example
in the theoretical computer science
community pollute that metric fitting
methods where um and so you have this D
hat you might want to look for it's a
matrix you might want to look for an
additive metric that is close as
possible to D hat in some measure maybe
the L infinity difference between them
with the smallest the largest difference
between two entries and except in some
special cases you often get sort of a
np-hard problems and
case or there's some approximation Allah
group um I guess it's not a convex
optimization thing she constraints on
such to this convict so it's sort of
nasty very clear
now there's another class of
optimization methods that instead of
working with this distance matrix work
directly with with the sequence data and
so one thing that you might want to do
is for example this the parsimony method
which is maybe one of the oldest ones is
doing the following piece well I'll give
you this data set and I'll give you a
particular tree for that tree you can
compute the pressing on your score which
corresponds to the following thing
they're going to assign a sequence to
every internal vertex in such a way that
you minimize the number of mutations
along the edges let's call the pressing
on this score and then you take the tree
that minimizes that okay so you're doing
this optimization problem over the space
of trees where you have a particular
score that corresponds to choosing
internal sequences that minimize the
amount of mutation that you need to
explain the data
now that might that might make sense for
you know that probably made more sense
for you know it makes sense when when
the the mutation rates are sort of low
or if you're looking at you know what I
talked about the you know the blood
squirting thing where the things are
that might be very rare these is a new
feature that arise and you might when he
was maximum personally they're just to
put those together into a tree but in
general since it's that sort of model
Bayes it gives you a method that are not
consistent so you're not guaranteed you
know correct true actually it's an old
result of pelvin saying that that you
can you can there's actual trees where
and you can show that you as the
sequence goes to infinity you're just
getting on the wrong tree out of it yes
very very good
I'll come back to that if I have time
now the the from the computational side
of course that parsimony is an np-hard
problem you can think of it as a it's
like a Steiner tree problem on the
boolean hypercube and say if you have
instead of a CG people that usually have
zero one sequences and each data point
it just each sequence is just one point
in this boolean hypercube and so these
are your Steiner no you're trying to
connect them with a tree and and each
edge corresponds to exactly one mutation
so you put a weight of one and finding
the Steiner tree there it gives you the
maximum parsimony tree and this is a NP
hard it's hard to approximate and so in
practice what biologists would do is is
some kind of local optimization you're a
stick you know they would be you have to
realize that now your your optimizer
over the space of trees this sort of
complicated objective function which is
not convex or anything and so you you
know one thing that you might do you
start from some tree and then you change
it by doing one of these tree changing
operations for example the render one's
better known ones would be sub tree
prune and regress where imagine this is
a tree so each one of these blobs is a
sub tree and I yank and I prune one of
the sub trees and I just move it
somewhere else I get in the tree on if I
could move through a street space in
this way and every time you know I could
look at which one of my neighbors as the
highest personally score and move over
there and so on and maybe sometimes you
make you know bigger moves or you start
from different places to try to sort of
get out of a local optimum answer and
and the bounds are develop sort of
heuristics that seem to work fairly well
but in general it's sort of a it's an
NPR in their problem so you don't really
know what they're getting out of getting
out of this
okay so this is NPR and not consistent
if you want to turn this into a
consistent method you can change the
objective and the natural thing to do
here is since you're interested in the
properties of this model this this
algorithm under model well it's the
natural statistical way to deal with
that it's a look at the maximum like for
your Ben Stein and so what I'm gonna do
here is I'm gonna space search over the
space of all trees and branch lengths
now and maximize the probability of
observing the data okay so for every
tree and every a branch length I can
compute the the probability of observing
the data under this particular model
each side is independent so I get a
product and then each one of these
things can be computed by dynamic
programming same thing was true over
here if I give you a tree there's a
simple way of computing the personally
score of I dynamic programming so you
can do the same thing from actual IQ and
so if you if you look for the tree and
the branch lengths at maximize this you
get the maximum likely a tree and that
has been shown to be a bit sure to be
consistent and it's sort of a generic
kind of property yes as a sequence line
goes to infinity this this guy
approximates the likelihood better and
better and for likely orders just follow
some convexity isn't that even you get
the right the truth free maximizes this
thing um now it's also unfortunately
np-hard Archer approximate it sort of
follows from from the fact that part of
maximum per summary itself is np-hard if
you just it turns out that you have very
low mutation rates the the likelihood if
you sort of expand in the branch line
the first term is the parsimony score
and you can sort of connect them
computationally in this way and show
that you get an NPR problem there so
once again what biologists do in
practice is they have these heuristics
that are actually supposed to be very
good where they do sort of local
optimization and
find the best possible tree em in that
space there's a related class of method
that I'm not going to talk about for
sure Bayesian methods where now you have
a prior and you sample from the
posterior by doing a sort of Markov
chain on the space of trees and branch
lengths and this is also on is a
computationally very heavy but it gives
biologists really like those methods
gives a lot of information so in
practice biologists actually prefer this
on athletes those who know what they're
doing use maximum likelihood and even
though it's it's it's slower right so
you can get a tree much faster use say
neighbor-joining which will be a
standard approach that's distance matrix
but there's a sort of large there's
there's a body of evidence that that
suggests that maximum likely is just
more accurate it just it works better
you get better trees of course for
biologists you know it might take a long
time to collect the data and so even if
they have to run the algorithm for a
month or two it might not be so
important and so they they might not
care that much about the computational
efficiency as long as they can run run
the thing but they they seem to be
getting better answers out of this then
and then out of this so our natural
question that's coming back to your
question here is well statistical
consensus these both of these types of
methods are so statistically consistent
can we say anything theoretically
speaking about why this one might be
better than a lot of methods of this
type and for that you want to do exactly
what you were suggesting which is to
look at at least that's what people have
done in recent work is to look at the
rate of convergence I so I know that if
I have infinite amount of data
eventually i converge to the right to
the right thing but how fast i converge
the trees are they could be any means if
I know something about the structure of
the tree maybe this is so I mean I
understand there are some result that
let's say that maybe not so much from a
computational point of view but from an
accuracy point of view how much data you
need to actually get a good
reconstruction there's certain classes
of trees that are easier than others and
I might get to that but that would be
one way in which you get to use the
structure to get a better answer
innocence
let me get to that you can ask okay
no sir only the first class is of this
type these two actually need the full
the full data you cannot reduce them to
computing Hamming distances so these
really take into account this little
higher-order patterns in the data across
species and so there has been work about
whether that transformation loses
information so much that you get sort of
different accuracy and it turns out to
be surprisingly that you can get more
out of these Hamming distances that you
might think so there's there's other
methods that I'm really sort of not
getting into here these are so the main
ones
there's something that I swept under the
rug and let me just mention them quickly
I actually already mentioned them but
just make it clear all right as I said
in reality if you look at you know if
you ignore the sort of very high level
rearrangements that's an interesting
problem itself to figure out where the
proteins that end up whether there's
sort of common proteins in between
different species there's the issue of
add the add the sort of more local level
there's these insertions and deletions
that are occurring and the way that
biologists deal with this is by doing
this pre-processing where they sort of
put gaps in there and try to UM to fit
the sequences as much as possible before
writing one of the sort of standard
reconstruction algorithm and it's
certainly a question as to whether this
step actually messes up the
there's been some very interesting
experimental work in particular in
recent years looking at this question
and taking the this thing further by
maybe trying to model the entire process
you know mutations and substitutions and
insertions and deletions and trying to
get both better alignments and better
trees at the same time you get is very
difficult a computational problem so
that's been one active area of research
where there's been lots of interesting
things and there's few result there's a
few Acosta's and I worked a little bit
on this question from a theoretical
point of view of trying to recovering
some of the standard results about these
methods from a theoretical point of view
in the case what you also allow
insertions and deletions I won't get
into yeah you could you could try the
model gaps as some extra state or you
could just treat it as some missing data
that you could maybe just keep only
those columns that don't have gaps or
something I know there's probably lots
of different ways that biologists deal
with those but the idea would be that if
I put a gap here is because maybe that
the the site that corresponds to G and
the ancestor actually was deleted and
these two species and so I don't see it
anymore and so I guess just by trying to
align everything that there might be
something missing over here multiple
signals there's no debate that it harder
if you do it at the same time and you
get this much more this very difficult
and I think there's experimental
evidence that you get better trees and
better alignments if you try to do both
at the same time but it's a challenging
the other thing I mentioned was the
other the different site might evolve at
different rates so some some sites might
be slower than the others so you can
think of a sort of rescaling of the
entire tree and that leads to something
called mixture models and there's lots
of questions there in particular as the
identifiability question and there's all
these negative results I Steve in
particular has a result like this where
you can show two different models
actually leave the same distribution of
data and therefore you can distinguish
between them and that becomes an issue
when you deal with with right rates
across sites or in generals and mixtures
of trees so the lots of interesting
result they're not so much algorithmic
back since I have maybe 20 minutes let
me tell you a little bit about all of
this question this question of rate of
convergence in the in the samples okay
so we said that we have different
methods that are statistically
consistent its maximum likely this is a
very different system a lot of distance
it's not that we're going to be
statistically consistent is if IIF I
gave you an up data eventually the
methods at least for theoretical point
of view you're guaranteed to converge to
the right thing but Samantha's are just
more accurate than others and this
statistical consensus see by itself it
doesn't tell me anything about which
ones are better than it is and so in
general what you'd like to be able to
say is you know you run a method on a
particular data set it off with some
tree it might not be exactly the right
thing but it might be at some distance
say in a subtree photograph distance and
you'd like to know something about you
know how far you're gonna become the
truth and that's independence we're in a
complicated way on all the parameters of
the model um and it seems to be a sort
of different difficult thing to
characterize instead the sort of their
approaches as arose and the theoretical
community computer science community is
to look at a sort of proxy which is this
rate of of convergence okay so before I
get to that let me just explain the
picture like so and this part I'm going
to think of my DNA sequences as pictures
I guess each each point each pixel is
one site in my DNA
instead of ACGT I've got black and white
okay so and I'm gonna visualize what
happens to my DNA over time by just
thinking of it as you know random noise
accumulating in my in my picture it's
like if I do this on a tree
and what do I get I get something like
this this is an actual simulation I
started at the root with a particular
picture a particular DNA sequence and
then along each one of these branches
you know the the mutations accumulated
and I get this sort of a noisy version
here and so on but the the the
simulation is maybe not that this is a
joint simulation would cost us the in
that quite the one problem is is this
that these two guys look the same and
they really only only have the same low
in noise level compared to the original
picture but the mutations are actually
in different position so these are
independent noisy channels and so you
repeat that over and over and so what
you what you get to see is this is your
data in the red box and you're trying to
reconstruct the tree and you can think
of this as a broadcasting process on
this noisy tree channel now you start at
the root or a particular image and you
get this sort of distorted picture at
the end of leaves and sort of a lot of
insight from this line of work come from
the idea that you know you're learning
this this graphical model this Markov
model on a tree and one key feature of
it is that you have all of these hidden
nodes of course sorry there's all these
sequences that I'm not actually seeing
but furthermore some of these sequence
is actually quite far from where the
data lives and understanding how well
sort of information propagates down this
tree is something that leads to a sort
of interesting insights about what makes
a good method what makes a bad method
and now you can sort of design new
approaches that reconstruct the tree and
at least in is it a more statistically
efficient way I guess I'm gonna to
formalize some of these results I'm
going to introduce what I'm going to
call the sample complexity which is just
the rate of convergence in the see
in the sequence linked I so I'm looking
at a particular method that
statistically consistent alas K goes to
infinity the sequence then goes to
infinity
I'm guaranteed to recover the Detroit
REE now when I'm gonna be interested in
is well I'll others how fast do I get
there I guess I'm gonna say that I
reconstruct within that sample
complexity of K if the probability of
reconstructing the correct tree which
sequence of length K is at least 1 minus
Delta and what I'm interested in is how
this K depend on the bottle and
particularly others its scale with sort
of different structural parameters of my
model Y so it will turn out that the
more leaves I have the more data I'm
going to end up needing the shorter the
branch lengths are or the shorter the
shortest branch length R is the more
data I'm gonna need I saw I've already
mentioned this parameter when we talked
about distance matrix methods I for them
to work it sort of clear that if there's
a very short branch is gonna make things
difficult
and then the depth of the tree is also
going to come in
I'll define more formally in a second
okay so our goal is you know this is may
not be exactly what biologists would
like to know about a particular method
but it's a good way to sort of try to
quantify how well different methods
extract data information from the data
by saying well if a method requires less
data than another one that maybe it's
just it is gonna give you more accurate
answers yes I sort of ever proxy that
that that we can prove a lot of things
about them it turns out to give some
interesting so what what can we prove
about this so the first class of methods
that was very heavily studied there was
these distance matrix methods are just
so easier to understand and so suppose
that I go back to this idea of thinking
about the distance between two leaves in
the juice Kander model as an expression
that I can actually estimate from the
data by looking at the Hamming distance
between sequences now if I want to know
how well a particular method is going to
work well I need to know how accurate my
distance is estimate is going to be and
that's going to depend on how much data
I okay so the more data I have the
the closer P hat is going to be to the
true the true additive metric and the
smaller them the the error is going to
be the more accurate the methods they're
going to be and so being a career is
really just you know just as this
binomial distribution up to a factor and
it's it's it's it's fairly easy to look
at just the variation that happened that
you have there in terms of K and so if
you apply sort of concentration
inequalities for example what you find
out is that if you want to estimate
distances with a certain precision towel
because I want to have to be towel close
to the real D up there then it turns out
that the the amount of data you need
actually depends on how far the species
are so the further apart they are in the
tree the more data you're going to need
if the distance between the ends em its
of grows exponentially with them it's
also going to grow one over this is like
tau square if tau small it's gonna go
like 1 over tau Square where towers of
precision again and then this log factor
over here because I want to be able to
do this for every pair of species so
there's an extra factor it comes from
and doing that Union bound ok so but in
general the more the the further apart
things are on the tree the more data I'm
going to need and so you immediately get
sort of a trivial result which is that I
can take em and replace it by the
diameter of my tree and that gives me an
estimate of how much data I need for a
sort of any distance matrix method to
work if M is the diameter here imagine
that every edge say is bounded as a
branch length that's bounded between two
constants and this diameter will be of
order in general could be linear right
if I have one of those
caterpillar type trees if I have n ly n
leaves and all of these branches say of
length 1 and the diameter could be as
large as n and so in general the amount
of data that I might need might scale
exponentially would end ok so as soon as
I have enough they'd have to see every
pair and then
and and I take the precision to be the
small a shortest branch like that I'm
gonna get a correct reconstruction now
this is not a very nice result but if
you look right at this weight sort of
exponential in n it grows very fast and
you might think well this is not going
to be great if there's not to be
actually tight for certain types of
methods so one of the most popular
method is better known that as his
neighbor joining it's sort of a version
of this clustering kind of idea that
works for the additive case and and
indeed for trees of this time it was
shown that indeed you need a really
gigantic amount of data in order to UM
to UM to get the the correct
reconstruction we type for a mill now
this result is very sort of
unsatisfactory because if you look at
this particular example right this is an
example where which has a lot of
structure in it and it should be very
easy to reconstruct right because what I
could do is I could you know if I know
that this is the structure I could just
sort of around each leaf reconstruct
just sort of locally what the tree looks
like and then try to patch those up
together and now if I believe my
estimate that the amount of data I need
depends on how far away I go well
building sort of small neighborhood
around each sleeve should be something
that doesn't require a lot of data and
therefore I should be able to build this
tree very easily with a very small
amount there's actually login over F
squared should be should be enough if
all my branches say have the same length
or or bounded by constants and so that
sort of led to a new class of distance
matrix methods that depends in instead
of depending on the diameter of the of
the tree depend on the depth of the tree
so the idea is that you have a tree that
has a long diameter but every edge here
is very close to the leaves it shouldn't
be hard to figure out what these what
these edges are correspond to but not
that much data and so one way to think
about this is is this distorted metric
idea of Marcel and
Valarie king and collaborator is to say
well if I give you a certain amount of
data K you can imagine that there's a
for a fixed precision there's you know
there's a maximum radius that I can
reach where now if I look at at this
particularly and all the leaves that are
within that radius the pairwise
distances are gonna be well approximated
at least within this towel and things
that are outside of it are gonna be all
distorted okay so you get this picture
here and now using this this this idea
well one one criterion in order to
reconstruct the tree correctly would be
well of course if the ball is of size of
the diameter then every pair is covered
and I'm good but that may not be
necessary so in this case for example if
I have balls of a small radius and I
think the union of all these balls I'm
actually going to cover every edge in
the tree and some on Twitter Li that
should be enough to reconstruct the
entire thing and so in general I'm gonna
define the depth of an edge by you know
if I take an edge here I look at that
the shortest path connecting two leagues
between them that's gonna be the death
of this edge and then I take the maximum
over this and the idea now is if I take
a diameter for this ball that's of the
size roughly of the depth of the tree
then when I think the Union overall of
the league is I'm going to cover every
edge in the tree and intuitively I might
be able to actually reconstruct
everything there and so air - it all
came up with this first algorithm that
actually showed that indeed that's the
case instead of a member very not truly
low that said that I don't actually need
to compute all of the distances I can
actually only use those that are some
somewhat short that corresponds to
things that are at distance from the
depth from each other and if you use
them in the right way the sort of the
combinatorial construction that shows
that you can actually recover the entire
tree and so one way to do this is just
again to build a tree around each leaf
in a ball of size roughly the depth and
then take the Union it sort of you know
give this sort of patchwork of thing
that you have to put together and it
turns out this can be done efficiently
so now you had a new result that says
that actually what's it suffice is
sequence length that grows like the
exponential of the depth instead of the
special to the diameter and that can
make a big difference because here for
example the depth is just constant
whereas over there the diameter over
here is actually order n there so you
get a much better convergence rate in
this sort of sample complexity in
essence I'm fine in a sense you're a
sort extracting information better why
is the the depth is in general
logarithmic if I if I assume that lambda
is between two constants F G and my tree
you know is is binary you know if if I
bifurcate at every level and I'm gonna
reach a leaf after I do this log in
times in there well if everything is is
bounded between two constant then it's
gonna be the same thing but yes and so
intuitively the DEP is gonna be an order
log in the worst case at least under
this particular assumption and so you
get this poly independence but in
general this so this is the formula sort
of interesting that's at this
exponential of the Deb versus the
exponential environment there's a lots
of work has been learned about this you
can push this further and actually I say
oh there's there's been some practical
methods that have been developed based
on the sort of divide and conquer kind
of idea where you build the tree locally
and sort of put them together and and
these and some of these methods are
quite quite good you can push this
further by saying you know one thing
that might be a little unsatisfactory
with my sample complexity definition is
that I'm I'm requiring that I get the
correct tree the perfect perfect
reconstruction we're probably 1 minus
Delta in general if I don't have enough
data you know it might not be possible
to actually get the correct tree and so
now you might wonder well how far am I
going to be from the truth tree if I
want a sort of an algorithm one way to
sort of formalize this is to say well I
can I can modify the previous algorithms
for reconstructing a partial trees I are
we going to start everything up to a
certain depth
using exactly the same kind of idea
where I build a thing locally depending
on how much data I have and then I put
those together and and you can show that
you know you actually get a sort of
optimal up to some constants in the
exponent and resolve in terms of how
much depth you reconstruct and if you
have edges that are too short you can
also figure out to contract them on the
way inside you can get a sort of partial
reconstruction that achieve in a sense
the best possible sample complexity at
least in in general and there's a whole
story that I'm not going to get into is
that you can push this even further if
you it turns out that there's a certain
regime of flour is where the mutation
rate is low enough where you can
actually completely get rid of this
dependence on the depth and that lee
sorts of interesting mathematics but i
want to talk about it yeah I had some
fun cartoons video I was before
finishing I want to go back to this
maximum-likelihood question right so I
I've showed you some some addict methods
I think the algorithms that I described
in the previous slides we're really just
you know I don't think anybody uses them
and practice that there or at least
nobody has tried to convince biologists
he was doing much in practice except
maybe for these other so heuristic that
were derived from them but the they're
really more sort of proofs that certain
certain things can be accomplished in
practice as I said biologists tend to
use maximum likelihood these days and
and what I just showed you sellout
doesn't really say anything about
maximum likelihood but a recent result
we were alive we were able to show that
indeed I didn't tell you what Steel's
conjecture is to forget about that but
the this dependence on the depth for
example can also be achieved using
maximum likelihood now we cannot prove
that maximum likely it is sort of better
in terms of sample complexity then
and then distance matrix methods okay
show that it's better than this certain
distance matrix methods in that regime
where things are owned with the depth
disappears but one sort of interesting
result that comes out of this is you
know I said that maximum likely it was
was np-hard in general but that's of
course in the worst case and if I give
you an arbitrary data set the computing
the maximum likelihood a tree on that
dataset won't be NPR but actually from
this from this result what you get is
that you know if your data is actually
structured if it's generated by a Markov
model on a tree and you have enough data
that these methods actually recover and
if you have at least sort of the
information theory amount of data that
you need to recover the the tree exactly
and then solve a maximum likely it
actually becomes polynomial time because
I can use these distance methods which
are fast they're getting a guaranteed to
recover the correct tree on these data
set with high probability and what this
result shows about maximum likelihood is
that with high probability the the
maximum likelihood is tree is the
correct tree and therefore I can get to
it using a distance method so maybe some
evidence that maybe maximum likelihood
at least on structured data centers
maybe not as hard as the np-hard results
suggest this particular thing is just a
result about about maximum likely or
just the the abstract maximum likelihood
problem if I if I can solve exactly the
the optimal you know the optimization
problem then the optimal as this
property it's not it's not an
algorithmic result person
so I can I can get to the truth you know
algorithmically by implementing things
by running these other algorithms but
it's not not really a way to sort of
maximum likely it's just I'm completely
out of time let me just mentioned one
open problem which is the same anything
about the mixing time of this Bayesian
kind of approaches some partial results
but very little is known about this
thank you
that's the kind of thing that biologists
are very interested in these days is you
know I didn't have time to get to it the
eye color this is a very simplistic
story when you have one gene from each
species and you're reconstructing an
evolutionary tree than that nowadays
biologists have access to thousands of
genes or entire genome and lots of
interesting things happen when you start
looking at at large scale David but not
only from a computational point of view
but even from a from a modeling point of
view from a difference point of view you
might have for example phenomena that
are creating inconsistencies between the
fringes the genes might have different
histories maybe because of of
Transportation slides this is this is
one no this is one example where you
might have a bacterial transfer or virus
transferring a piece of DNA between two
unrelated species and now this
particular gene now as a history that's
completely different from the story
connection between what Steve was
talking about and Andy's I could imagine
doing a coalescent now if I take into a
kind of population level processes on
each one of these branches I could have
a tree where on each branch I'm running
these this coalescing process and it
turns out that you have interesting
phenomena where certain genes if they
failed at coalesce in their first common
ancestor might lead to trees that have a
different topology than VM the actual
species history and now you have to find
ways to sort of combine this and figure
out with the whole evolutionary
histories and so particularly now you
might wonder if for example if you're
looking at case like this is a tree is a
tree even what you want to reconstruct
maybe what you want to redo something I
was a tree which loops in there that
corresponds to these gene transfer is
over or ibrid speciation events and that
opens up a whole new area as this book
by usin at all 2010 to describe some of
the computational work that was done in
this area so generally speaking it's
sort of this is aware of a lot of the
work this
is taking into account for genomic scale
no further questions thank you